what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we got some
spider-man things to talk about some
good spider-man stuff but i want to get
this out of the way first yeah i heard
about that moon night leak not gonna
show it heard about some takedowns that
have already started happening just
gonna give my two cents looks great
looks awesome i was not hit with the
feeling of oh i don't know about this
guys you know like a lot of the time
when suits leak you have people saying
just wait for like the color correction
and the post-production to be done on it
which is always an understandable
argument but for moon knight for that
one gritty image it's pretty awesome
it's awesome stuff i'll say that it's
really cool really cool i'm really
satisfied with what we're seeing so far
but anyway on to this spider-man thing
so we've got two things to talk about
today first thing is willem dafoe
confirms without confirming we'll get
into it
he's in spider-man no way home it's
pretty funny stuff and then the other
part is tom hardy is eagerly pushing for
a venom spider-man crossover and i have
some thoughts as to why that already
might be in development the first order
of business here uh willem dafoe was
doing an interview it was with the rap
pretty much here's what happened and i
should give credit where credit is due i
actually first heard about this news
from warren when he sent me a screenshot
of what he was working on i think his
video is now live he does talk about
this and more in his uh recent video
cosmic wonder thanks buddy when asked if
his comment on his potential involvement
in no way home would actually just be
no comment defoe said
i'm afraid so i got lots of stuff
happening and you know i always feel
like when a film comes out that's when
it's time to talk about it
here's the funny part about this
defoe
he didn't say whether or not he would be
in spider-man no way home but he did say
that if he's in it he's gonna say no
comment yeah but if he's not in the
movie he doesn't have to deal with any
of the wordplay if he's not in a movie
all he has to do is say i'm not in it he
has none of these concerns to worry
about so by him just saying no comment
that's pretty much confirming i'm gonna
be in the movie when he's going out of
his way saying if i'm in it i'm gonna
say no comment yeah because if he's not
in it all he has to say is no i'm not in
it yeah plain and simple we're done heck
if he's in it he could just say no and
plain and simple we're done because at
this point you don't have to be honest
about those things you know yeah we were
very forgiving of when these actors lie
to us
yeah these marvel actors are always like
the surprise we were hoping for at the
end i don't know i mean i feel like
that's the my favorite low-key
confirmation of all of them yet just
because it is so like yup that's my
answer that's what i'm sticking with
yeah he's pretty much confirmed it
spider versus in full swing guys what do
you think about what willem dafoe has
said let's move on to the next thing
here tom hardy was doing an interview
with esquire uk where he was of course
asked about a spider-man venom crossover
so i'm going to hand this off to john
john and your best tough brooding
british accent because we all know how
tom hardy is that threatening british
father that he is definitely
i would be remiss if i wasn't trying to
steer any kind of connectivity hardy
told the outlet i wouldn't be doing the
job if i wasn't awake and open to any
opportunity or eventually this is more
idris elba really eventuality or be
excited by that obviously there's a
large canyon to leap to be bridged by
one person alone and it would take much
higher level of diplomacy and
intelligence sitting down and talking to
take on an arena such as that all right
a little bit of christian bail a little
bit of interest but everything not at
all tom hardy
no no tom hardy everyone could do a bane
but no one could do an actual tom hardy
oh god
i love how when he's talking about this
he's acting like it all falls on his
shoulders yeah like it's all me i'm the
only one fighting for this no one
apparently wasn't
me
i'm the only one who's trying to get him
the director
this is my deadpool sony doesn't care
about having spider-man in a venom movie
it's only me i think it's already oh
wait wait there's a little bit more
there's a little bit more before we go
into our thoughts john take it away
should both sides be willing and it'd be
beneficial to both sides i don't see why
it couldn't be i hope and strongly with
both hands push eagerly towards that
potential and would do anything to make
it happen within what's right in
business but it would be foolish not to
head towards the olympic games if you're
running a hundred meters so yeah i want
to play on that field
i think whether whatever you think about
the movie venom
whatever you think about like how
lackluster it was we personally had a
lot of fun when we watched it it was one
of those movies where i'm like yeah no i
i see all the flaws doesn't mean i
didn't have a great time and then unless
there be carnage looks even better and
more confident i'm looking forward to
venom let there be carnage a lot i'm a
little bummed that it got delayed
now when we're talking solely about tom
hardy though eddie brock venom i think
what a lot of people were saying even
people who didn't like the movie a lot
of them were saying but tom hardy's good
you know yeah but tom hardy's really
good so regardless whether you like it
or not i feel like anyone will be
excited at the possibility of tom hardy
and spider-man crossing over into a film
i think this is already in development
behind the scenes you know these these
guys are always like
years ahead yeah years ahead well think
of all the things that tom hardy has put
on his instagram and taken down a venom
in photoshop pictures with spider-man
like clearly he's had this on his mind
for a long time i mean you were looking
up an article from cinema blend there's
an interview a long time ago a fun one
with benedict cumberbatch and uh tom
holland where tom holland was like i
just really loved the idea someone's
called being teamed up with a guy who
does magic because it totally
contradicts what he knows a lot of idea
that is real science that peter parker
talks about and there's this doctor
strange gibberish who's like the time
rift and the thing and the thing it's
just kind of fun
now
he was doing that with end game and then
when i saw the movie i was like the hell
are you talking about it
that's not good
so the cinemablend article had come out
because it was um saying that tom
holland accidentally starts because i
remember in that interview benner to
cumberbatch was like stop stop or
something yeah yeah
and were they talking about spider-man
the way home when they should have been
talking about avengers end game and they
got themselves mixed up my point being
is that interview came out during end
game and let's say that was part of
spider-man no way home either way we
know how far in advance these guys plan
and it's so obvious they are building up
to eventually get that venom spider-man
crossover happening so a lot of people
like when tom hardy's talking about this
canyon you know being the rift with the
whole like how do we make sony and
marvel really just operate
capacity come home for just a nice
christmas dinner that's what the canyon
is that tom hardy's referring to look we
already know
alfred molina who is from a solely a
sony spider-man movie we already know
that electro who's only solely from a
spider-man movie and now willem dafoe
same deal are all in
spider-man no way home and then we see
the morbius trailer where they have a
spider-man image on it venom never
acknowledges spider-man venom let there
be carnage trailer hasn't shown us any
spider-man but morbius features an uh a
villain that was introduced in the mcu
vulture and they have a spider-man in
the background i think it's already in
development
behind the scenes they're already like
figuring out what it is to be done
because the way tom hardy talks about it
i'm trying guys it's like maybe we can
do it but you know there's a lot of
things we got to work around and it's
kind of rough but maybe i'm going to try
to get it done
i'm like dude who are you bullshitting
yeah
this is already happening we already
know this is happening way too much
money to be left on the table by not
having this happen especially with the
surprise hit that venom yes and the way
in which it was totally and the amount
of faith it sounds like at least from
you know what you hear on you know
speculation that sony has in morbius and
venom two you know it seems like they
want to keep expanding and that's the
perfect way to do it and they've already
talked about
at least hints at or you know maybe the
mcu could see some of these characters
or maybe we could lend some of them to
the spunk it's to me a matter of when
not if any any longer yeah it's gonna
come eventually and i already think they
have a plan yeah i would be i i would be
very much surprised i'd be very much
taken aback if that's not the case peter
parker will return to to face eddie
brock in some capacity in spider-man 4.
but guys what do you think about what
tom hardy's saying and do you believe
that they actually have one already in
development leave your thoughts down
below thank you so much for being here
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button hopefully there's a
trailer that comes out of cinemacon for
no way home even if it is getting
delayed or whatever hopefully there's a
trailer i just gotta see something gotta
see something
see you guys
[Music]
you